it's really cool that MIT flew an entire
25 piece big band all the way to Puerto
Rico
when I was a freshman first joining the
ensemble it's not something I would have
ever imagined
going on tour with Miguel's then on in
Puerto Rico
[Music]
now that you saw the demonstration that
they had I think to create a ballet no
Grenoble Ontario he wanted to see if
there were any volunteers to come up and
dance
[Music]
my parents are a Nigerian they listen a
lot of like traditional like African
music and in terms of like from a
rhythmic standpoint it's actually very
similar
[Music]
a big part of mi t--'s vision is to take
all the skills and the knowledge that
the students have acquired and to go
forth and spread it and and try to use
those skills for good and so I really
think that this trip is very much an
extension of mi t--'s dedication to
trying to change the world positively
[Music]
my name is Peter I'm from Massachusetts
I go to the Masjid today we've been
talking to middle school and high
schoolers and and my goal throughout
this process is to inspire them to begin
thinking about ways that they can
directly impact their own communities
this area was very affected by Hurricane
Maria with flooding of a few feet of
water that stayed inside the houses for
16 days and they had no power for around
4 months
I've seen a remarkable example of the
resiliency of the human spirit and
people's ability to recover in any
situation close to 300 schools have been
closed as a result of the storm and the
people are now moving to reclaim these
properties and convert them into
something else like a multicultural Arts
Centre that will give students and
artists in the community a place to
rehearse or a place to perform or just a
place to gather and share their art in
the school we just visited there's no
electricity and so right now they're
they're trying to figure out how can
they take solar panels and batteries and
supply the power required to run that
facility I'm extremely grateful for you
guys being here this week I'm sure you
know how much this means to me and how
long we've worked to make this happen
this has exceeded all my expectations
and hopefully you got something really
good from it I can assure you that
everyone you met this weekend everyone
wherever you play her to speak got a lot
from it and it's gonna make a difference
in their life so thank you so much for
being here I really really appreciate it
I get so much joy out of I've seen this
kind of thing happen I mean it's the
greatest thing that could happen and
it's fluid whereas we wore that music
could give me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]